low-income countries most of them in
africa have received just 0.6
of all vaccines
we understand and support every
government's responsibility to protect
its own people it's natural
but vaccine equity is not charity
it's in every country's best interests
no country can vaccinate its way out of
the pandemic alone
the longer vaccine inequity persists
the more opportunity this virus has to
spread and evolve in ways we cannot
predict
nor prevent
we're all in this together
we call on every member state to support
the targets to vaccinate 40 percent of
the population of every country by the
end of this year
and 70 percent
by the middle of next year
103 countries
still have not reached the 40 percent
target
and more than half of them are at risk
of missing it by the end of the year
mainly because they cannot access the
vaccines they need and most of them in
africa
even
as some countries are now beginning to
vaccinate groups at very low risk of
severe disease
or to give boosters to healthy adults
just one in four health workers in
africa has been vaccinated
this is unacceptable
with emerging evidence
of some waning vaccine immunity against
infection
it's clear that in future countries will
need tailored booster strategies
who's position remains that health
workers
older people and other at risk groups
must be vaccinated first in all
countries
before those
at low risk of serious diseases
and before boosters are given to already
vaccinated healthy adults
there is no doubt that vaccines have
saved many lives and helped to quell the
pandemic in many countries
countries that have achieved the highest
vaccination rates are now seeing a
decoupling between cases and does
but in too many countries and
communities
the bright light of vaccines has also
become a blind blinding light to the
continued need for other tools to stop
this virus spreading
to stop it overwhelming our health
systems
and to stop it killing
vaccines save lives
but they do not fully prevent infection
or transmission
until we reach high levels of
vaccination in every country
suppressing transmission
remains essential
we don't mean lockdowns
which are a last resort in the most
extreme circumstances
we mean a tailored and comprehensive
package of measures that strike a
balance between protecting the rights
freedoms and livelihoods of individuals
while protecting the health and safety
of the most vulnerable members of
communities
ending this pandemic is not about
vaccines or
it's about
vaccines and
excellencies dear colleagues and friends
covet 19 has now killed more than 5
million people
and they're just
the reported deaths
the excess deaths caused by the virus
and by disruption to essential health
services are far higher
an unknown number
live with post-covered condition
or long-covered a condition we're only
beginning to understand
health systems continue to be
overwhelmed
millions have missed out on essential
life-saving health services for
non-communicable diseases
and
mental health
progress against hiv tuberculosis
malaria and many other diseases has told
or gone backwards
millions of children have missed out on
vaccinations for other life-threatening
days
and months of education
millions of people have lost their jobs
or been plunged into poverty
the global economy is still clowing its
way out of recession
political divisions have deepened
nationally and globally
inequalities have widened
science has been undermined
misinformation has abounded
and it will all happen again
unless you
the nations of the world
can come together to say with one voice
never again
at its heart
the pandemic is a crisis of solidarity
and sharing
the lack of sharing of information and
data by many countries in the early days
of the pandemic hindered our collective
ability to get a clear picture of its
profile and trajectory
the lack of sharing of biological
samples hindered our collective ability
to understand how the virus was evolving
the lack of sharing of ppe tests
vaccines technology know-how
intellectual property and other tools
hindered our collective ability to
prevent infections and save lives
and the lack of a consistent and
coherent global approach has resulted in
a splintered
and disjointed response breeding
misunderstanding
misinformation and mistrust
the fabric of multilateralism has been
frayed
kovid 19 has exposed and exacerbated
fundamental weaknesses in the global
architecture for pandemic preparedness
and response
complex and fragmented governance
inadequate financing
and insufficient systems and tools
voluntary mechanisms have not
solved these
challenges
the best way we can address them is with
a legally binding agreement between
nations
an accord forged from the recognition
that we have no future
but a common future
nations coming together to find common
ground is the only way to make
sustainable progress against common
threats
it's not perfect
and it's not a panacea
it takes compromise
no one gets everything they want but
that's better than so many missing out
on what they need